esta frase me parece increíble lo que
haces en la oscuridad es lo que te lleva
a la luz pues demuestra toda la
dedicación y la chamba que hay atrás de
cualquier logro y te demuestra que nada
en la vida se consigue fácil
les voy a contar un poco acerca de mí
desde chiquita si hay una palabra que me
define está de todas maneras sería
curiosidad alrededor de los 5 años me
regalaron unos biberones de juguetes
para que el muñeco tomara uno de leche y
uno de jugo lo que me parecía increíble
era que cuando volteaba el biberón el
líquido se iba consumiendo como si el
muñeco de verdad tomase el líquido y
cuando lo paraba todo el líquido
regresaba esto me pasaba de vueltas no
le entendía le preguntaba a la gente
grande que era lo que estaba pasando y
me contestaban cosas que en los cinco
años ya me sonaban y lógicas como por
ejemplo el muñeco se lo está tomando
pero cuando lo volteaba solo igual igual
funcionaba o me decían simplemente
desaparece como cómo va a ser esto la
verdad que todas esas maderas por un
buen tiempo pero este pensamiento de no
entender qué es lo que está pasando me
volvía y me volvía cada vez más loca el
tener dos dije saben que ya no importa
rompo una
y la verdad la rompí para ver cómo era
dentro y lo descubrí todo entendí cómo
funcionaba y cuál era el mecanismo en
ese momento vi la luz y me causó tanta
tanta felicidad que desde ahí cada
juguete que me regalaban y no lo
entendía lo tenía que abrir
o romper para ver cómo era dentro sorry
mamá por andar rompiendo todos los
muñecos que me regalaban
hablando de mi mamá les voy a contar una
historia
yo siempre ajuste de chiquita y que yo
creo que me ha marcado de por vida y es
por ella que es ahora que soy la persona
quién soy en una época donde solo los
hombres podían ser choques
es decir jinetes de carrera mi mamá ha
decidido que ya también quería hacerlo
bueno ya se imaginarán todos los
obstáculos por los que ella estuvo que
pasar le decían este no es un deporte de
mujeres le decían las mujeres no son
yogis les decían las mujeres no tienen
la fuerza para poder manejar un caballo
sin embargo tras todos los obstáculos ya
les voy a decir para que le inviten
alguna próxima charla ted porque creo
que le toca ella lo logró lo logró y no
sólo lo logró fue la primera y horqueta
mujer del mundo y no sólo eso fue la
campeona fue la mejor
bueno y fue la mejor y con eso le tapó
la boca a todos los que no le querían
dar sus caballos para que ella los corra
pero había una persona que desde el
comienzo siempre la apoyaba y le daba a
sus caballos para que ella los corra esa
persona luego se convirtió en su esposo
y bueno fue mi papá
lamentablemente él ya no nos acompaña
hace poco tiempo pero no importa la vida
sigue y quizás de ahí saqué el patrón de
casarme con una persona que me apoyen
todas mis locuras es por eso que con
domingo mi esposo nos metimos en esta
locura de que querer crear tu startup
y hoy nos comenzó porque el comienzo
sentía que no era posible que viviésemos
en una ciudad donde habían tantas
charlas fiestas conferencias festivales
eventos como este y nosotros pensemos
que todo lo que para ser un miércoles es
ir al cine oa comer
la verdad que no y peor aún si querías
comprar tu entrada era como regresar a
los años 90
este fue mi proyecto de tesis cuando
estudiaba una maestría en madrid pero
como todos saben las tesis es un chan
cocom de papel que se quedan en tu cajón
bueno en mi caso en mi computadora
así que cuando regrese a perú de verdad
no tenía ni idea qué cosa quería hacer
no sabía que iba a ser de mi vida donde
iba a trabajar ni siquiera sabía dónde
iba a vivir y sin embargo me ofrecieron
regresar a la corporación en la que
trabajaba antes una corporación
increíble iba a tener un horario normal
de 9 a 6 es más todos los viernes del
año salíamos super temprano iba a tener
un excelente sueldo seguridad porque
sabía que iba a pasar al día siguiente
en quincena en fin de mes estabilidad
económica y también emocional y de
verdad poco estrés sin embargo todo esto
que les conté en el biberón empezó otra
vez en mi cabeza y sentía y que paso
hacia omite sis y qué pasa si hago mi
proyecto realidad un poco hice una
comparación y me di cuenta que si lo
hacía realidad iba a tener que trabajar
24 horas al día no iba a tener sueldo
iba a estar en una inseguridad extrema
en la incertidumbre de no saber cómo
llegar en la quincena a fin de mes y con
un niveles
altísimo
teniendo este cuadro comparativo no sé
quién en su sano juicio escogería el de
la derecha
pero la verdad es que yo lo escogí y lo
escogí porque no quería que pasen 10
años y quedarme con el que hubiese
pasado si quería por lo menos intentarlo
intentarlo arriesgarme tachar de mi
lista fracasar no me importaba pero por
lo menos hacerlo es así que decidí
lanzarme a la piscina y junto conmigo se
lanzó mi socio mi esposo o bueno en
verdad yo creo que lo empuje
pero la cosa es que los dos juntos
decidimos hacer esto realidad
al comienzo hicimos todos nosotros
mismos todos lo manejamos con los
recursos que teníamos la verdad es que
no teníamos ni un sol pero sí teníamos
nuestras computadoras teníamos una
pizarra teníamos nuestro cerebro
nuestras manos y las ganas de dedicarnos
24/7 a este proyecto
en el camino nos fuimos encontrando y
nos seguimos encontrando con miles de
barreras no sólo laborales sino también
personales a esa edad tus amigos
volteas y ves que todos sus amigos se
casan ves que se compran un depa que
alquilan un depa se mudan se compran un
carro y yo me tuve que regresar a vivir
a la casa de mi mamá porque no tenía ni
un sol para poder alquilar un depa y
también iba a la casa de mi suegra en
busca de comida porque tampoco tenía
para almorzar y para comer solo para que
sepan hace cinco años creamos join us y
recién hace cinco meses nos pudimos
mudar juntos y alquilar un depa todavía
seguimos yendo a comer en la casa de mi
suegra
comenzamos con el 1% y en el camino
fuimos desarrollando todo sobre la
marcha las patadas como podamos a veces
nos daban unos retos que parecían
imposibles sin embargo decíamos si si se
puede si podemos hacerlo y ya después
por atrás no veíamos cómo hacerlo nos
rompimos la cabeza en algún momento yo
pensé que iba a llegar ese 100% iba a
decir listo esto está terminado funciona
pero la verdad y lo que nadie te dice es
que nunca llegas ese 100% todo el día
sigues mejorando si es innovando sigues
pensando en qué más hacer sigues
pensando en tu equipo
en algún momento también me dijeron
ustedes no tienen experiencia en eventos
grandes fue ahí donde dijimos no vamos a
conseguir el evento más grande y lo
logramos hicimos el evento que es más
grande que se haya hecho alguna vez en
toda la historia de perú fue un evento
para 1.5 millones de personas y salió
increíble ya se imaginarán toda la
chamba que hubo atrás de esto y con eso
les tapamos la boca a todo lo que decía
no tienen experiencias en eventos
grandes
la verdad
es que suena súper bien crear tu
startups y también ciento veces que
están de moda todas estas palabras como
si yo estar tan emprendedora como
founder founder pero lo que de verdad
nadie te cuenta es toda la chamba de
dedicación que hay atrás de todo esto
para lograrlo
mis amigos me ven como si yo soy mi
propio jefe tengo todo el tiempo del
mundo como si pudiese trabajar desde la
playa creen que soy exitoso y la mejor
es que creen que soy millonaria porque
salgo de repente en la tele en una
revista o porque doy una charla como
esta pero nada de esto es verdad
realmente hacer esto es un sacrificio
grande sacrificas muchas cosas
tiempo con tu familia tiempo con tus
amigos
bueno para terminar y ese es el último
slide quiero decirles que alcanzar una
meta es algo que no es nada fácil en el
camino te vas a ir encontrando con
muchas barreras y tienes que irla
superarlo pero mi consejo es que si de
verdad quieren hacerlo y si de verdad
les gusta pues háganlo láncense en la
piscina equivoquen se no se rindan la
perseverancia es la clave para llegar a
cualquier meta que ustedes se propongan
es por eso que ahora en join us nosotros
y todo el equipo que tenemos
seguimos trabajando súper duro para
poder algún día llegar a la luz gracias
[Aplausos]